the tourist town valkenburg has come
back to life local businesses protesting
against the government's lockdown by
opening their doors
it has been really difficult to be in
this situation for a long time not only
us but all business owners museums and
cinemas have to pay the price and for us
it's become really hard falconburg is
five kilometers away from belgium and
germany where all restaurants and shops
are open disgruntled entrepreneurs had
to watch their customers flock across
the border to shop eat and be
entertained for the past four weeks so
this is basically called civil
disobedience right no this is a
demonstration
and it's it's
a fundamental right
to express
how you think about things and as a
mayor of this city i allow this as a
demonstration it's a it's it's a very
quiet
uh and friendly
uh demonstration but very quickly
it's crowdy but i see happy faces
it is clear that many and the
netherlands are fed up with the
government's covet 19 policies they're
seen as inconsistent and lacking a
long-term vision under pressure from
protests like these the government seems
to have no choice but to relax what have
been the strictest lockdown measures in
europe
what we are doing now is taking a very
big step taking a risk i think it's a
responsible risk in the next 10 days we
will look exactly at what we can learn
from abroad and what we can also learn
from here in the netherlands
but the government is warning that the
omicron peak is yet to come and will
likely paralyze parts of society and add
to the growing number of death the
netherlands saw higher numbers of excess
mortality in the past few months
compared to other european nations
some of those definitely could have been
prevented not all of them during a
pandemic of course but some probably
could have been prevented either by
introducing measures earlier so
infections would have been prevented or
we could have started the booster
campaign earlier as other countries did
while the government has caved into
public pressure by partially lifting
lockdown measures it's now hoping the
decision won't cause hospitals to be
flooded once again step faster al
jazeera
boy